صوتت لجنة استشارية لقاح إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) للتو
ضد السماح بجرعة ثالثة
من اللقاح المعزز للقاح شركة فايزر المرغوبة
لكل من يبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا أو أكبر
على الرغم من حقيقة أن البيت الأبيض
قال إن ذلك سيحدث ،
وهو رد الفعل الرئيسي
الذي يقول العلماء إنه لا توجد
بيانات كافية لدعمه  هذه اللقطة المعززة
لمعظم الأمريكيين ، لكن يبدو أن مستشاري إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير
يدعمون
المعززات للأمريكيين الأكبر سنًا ،
فلنحضر إليزابيث كوهين إليزابيث من CNN ،
علمنا أن اجتماع اليوم سيكون
مثيرًا للجدل ، هل توقع أي شخص التصويت بـ "لا" على
الرغم من
أنك تعرف ما الذي توقعه بعض الأشخاص
بعدم التصويت.  كنت أتحدث إلى المصادر هذا
الصباح ، بدأ الأمر يبدو وكأنه لم يكن جيدًا
لأن التصويت كان بشكل كبير جدًا لا ،
وأعتقد أن هذا كان مفاجئًا ولكن دعني
أتحدث عن سبب تصويتهم بـ "لا" أو
أحد الأسباب التي دفعتهم إلى التصويت.  لا يوجد نوع من
النظرية التي تم طرحها إذا
أعطيت كل شخص تعزيزات فسوف
تقلل من العدوى حتى
لا يصاب الشباب بالعدوى ونحن  اعلم أن
الأشخاص الأصغر سنًا بعد تلقيحهم
إذا أصيبوا بالعدوى يكونون بخير عادةً
ولكن النظرية كانت أوه ربما هؤلاء
الشباب سينشرونها في جميع الأنحاء
وسيكون ذلك سيئًا وأعتقد أن الكثير من
الناس يشككون في هذه النظرية ،
يشكك الناس في النظرية  عما إذا كان الأمر
يستحق إعطاء التعزيزات للأشخاص الذين
تقل أعمارهم عن 60 عامًا. لذلك دعونا
نستمع إلى الدكتور بول أوفيت ، إنه
متخصص في الأمراض المعدية في
جامعة بنسلفانيا ، لقد كان
أه نوعًا ما
كان لديه الكثير من الأسئلة  حول
هذه المعززات لعدة أسابيع حتى الآن
وتحدث عن هذه النظرية ،
فلنستمع
إلى أن الجرعة الثالثة من لقاحات mrna
تزيد من عيار الأجسام المضادة المعادلة الخاصة بالفيروس
ومن المرجح أن
تقلل من حدوث عدوى أعراض إعادة النمذجة بدون
أعراض
والتي ترتبط بالعدوى في
ذلك الوقت  يصبح السؤال هو ماذا
سيكون تأثير ذلك على تابوت
الوباء الذي قد لا يكون كل هذا
القدر وبعبارة أخرى ما الذي سيحدث في كثير من الأحيان؟  ar
إنك إذا قمت بتلقيح مجموعة من
الأشخاص دون سن الستين
ولم تحصل على الكثير من الإصابات المفاجئة ،
فأنت تعرف تلك العدوى
حيث يكون الأشخاص بدون أعراض أو مرضى بالكاد ،
هل يهم حقًا أنه يقول
إنه يعتقد أنه ليس كذلك  ومن الواضح أنني
أعتقد أن غالبية الأعضاء يتفقون
معه